-You guys, we are in the
second week of March Madness.
-What?
-Yeah.
And we're down to the Sweet 16.
And every year, we pick a team
to root for,
and this year we picked Gonzaga.
And, well, unfortunately,
last night,
they lost to the Arkansas
Razorbacks, who were great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a great team. Yeah.
They're a good team.
So, now I'd like to take a
minute and speak to my Bulldogs,
because right now...
I know you're probably feeling
pretty low.
But let me tell you...
you got a lot to be proud of.
Gonzaga...
Gonzaga, you lost.
But here's the good news.
You played well.
You're a good team,
and hopefully someday
you're gonna go all the way.
But look at the bright side.
You still have spring break.
Get out of Spokane
and go to Cancún.
And you got those rowdy rags.
You already got your towel.
We just wanted to say
that we're proud of you.
You got to respect
how far you came.
And besides, Sweet 16 is
a much cooler name than Elite 8.
Who cares about being elite,
when you can be sweet?
[ Laughter ]
Go, Zags.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, Timmy...
time to shave that mustache.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
♪♪